[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the formation purpose and
timeline of each of albus damodal's
armies now i know what you may be
thinking each of dumbledore's armies
didn't he only have just the one
well of course you are correct in
identifying that only one of
dumbledore's armies was literally named
dumbledore's army there were actually at
least
three other groups which formed around
the leadership of albus dumbledore while
each of these groups were created to
serve their own unique purpose they all
were underground unsanctioned martial
groups formed in support of dumbledore
during times of wizarding warfare let's
get started the first group is one that
has only recently been revealed to fans
of the wizarding world
they are a rather odd assembly of
characters who have been introduced
through the fantastic beasts films
no doubt you will have figured out that
i'm referring to newt scamander his
assistant bunty his brother theseus
jacob kowalski tina goldstein yusuf
karma and yulali hex
from previous films and current trailers
for the upcoming secrets of dumbledore
we know that newt was of course the
famous major zoologist who later writes
fantastic piece and where to find them
theseus commander was newt's older
brother and a talented aura working for
the british ministry of magic
jacob kowalski was the american nomad
whom new to befriend in new york during
his stateside trip to find magical
creatures popentina or tina goldstein
the american half-blood witch whom newt
also befriended and let's be honest fell
for during that same trip to new york
use of karma was the french pureblood
wizard of senegalese ancestry whom we
were introduced to in the crimes of
grindelwald and finally eulali hicks an
american witch born to no-maj parents
and the charms professor at ilvermorny
school of witchcraft and wizardry
performing sometime in the 1930s the
purpose of this first iteration of
dumbledore's army was quite clear to
stop the gelit grindelwald or as theseus
commander puts it this is the team
that's going to take down the most
dangerous wizard in over a century in
any case this rather diverse group of
witches wizards and a muggle came
together throughout the fantastic beast
films through circumstance and
friendship
to take down grindelwald with that in
mind you may argue that they formed an
allegiance to newt scamander not albus
dumbledore however hasn't everything
newt stand throughout the films been in
answer to a request from dumbledore i
also think it's quite obvious that we
will see formal action and direction
from albus himself in the upcoming film
firstly because he seems to be in almost
every frame of the trailers and then of
course there's the fact the movie is
quite literally named after him and then
of course there's the fact that many
fans have taken to the internet to
express they believe this group was
dumbledore's first unofficial army
and well you don't have to tell me twice
the second group of witches and wizards
that came together under the leadership
of albus dumbledore was the first order
of the phoenix
founded in secret by dumbledore the
purpose of this covert magical society
was to put an end to lord voldemort
during his rise to power in the 1970s
at this time the dark lord had assembled
his own army of death eaters and was
bringing destruction and murder to the
wizarding world through his hateful
ambition
aside from albus members of the first
order included sirius black edgar bones
karadok dearborn daedalus diggle el
firestoge aberforth dumbledore benji
fenwick arabella fig mundungus fletcher
rubius hagrid alice longbottom frank
longbottom remus lupin marlene mckinnon
dorcas meadows aleister moody peter
pettigrew sturgis podmore james potter
lily potter fabian pruitt gideon pruitt
severus snape and emmeline vance this
group resistance society army or
whatever you want to call it played a
very important role in helping end the
first wizarding war voldemort was
inevitably taken down in 1981 by an
infant harry potter and the magical
protection from his mother's love
as you well know harry's mother was
order of the phoenix member lily potter
sadly this night also brought the loss
of many order members including the
deaths of lily and james potter the
imprisonment of sirius black and the
betrayal of peter pettigrew although the
first order was disbanded after
voldemort's defeat they reconvened in
1995 after the dark lord rose back to
power and the second wizarding war began
once again this group of witches and
wizards rose to the cool under the
direction and leadership of albus it
would seem that the group only reformed
after harry told dumbledore that
voldemort was back
dumbledore believed harry and that was
enough motivation for the rest of the
members to restore the order in
opposition of the dark lord
while the second order was comprised of
many of the original members newcomers
included kingsley shacklebolt mineover
mcgonagall arthur bill charlie molly
fred george and ron weasley hestia jones
nymphadora tonks fleur de la cour harry
potter and hermione granger although
they participated in combat such as the
battle of the department of mysteries in
1996 the second order remained
underground in an effort to protect its
members as so many remembered how
ruthless voldemort and his death eaters
had been back in the 70s
tragically this was not enough to save
dumbledore who effectively orchestrated
his own death after condemning himself
to die by touching marvolo gaunt's
cursed ring
despite their grief over losing their
unrivaled leader dumbledore the second
order marched on under the joint
direction of mcgonagall shacklebolt and
moody until his death in the summer of
1997. the second order came to the aid
of hogwarts students and staff during
the battle of hogwarts in 1998
which saw the final defeat of voldemort
and the ultimate dissolution of his
death eaters
this of course brings us to albus
dumbledore's fourth and final group of
magical soldiers the student-run
organization that formed in the name of
dumbledore dumbledore's army
otherwise known as the d.a dumbledore's
army is actually the only magical arms
group discussed in this video that does
not directly involve albus dumbledore
himself the secret organization was
founded by hermione and led by harry in
an effort to teach students defense
against the dark arts
this meant that the group was learning
combative and martial magic so that they
could defend themselves against lord
voldemort his death eaters or other
forces of dark magic
dumbledore's army was originally formed
as a result of that year's defense
against the dark arts professor dolores
umbridge refusing to teach them anything
in class
but as the second wizarding war raged on
the d.a evolved into a group that proved
themselves to be instrumental in the
defeat of voldemort dumbledore's army
first began to take shape in 1995 but
gained momentum as the school year went
on after an initial meeting at the hogs
head-in in hogsmeade the students would
meet in the room of requirement at
hogwarts in these meetings harry would
teach members who came from gryffindor
hufflepuff and ravenclaw what he had
learned over the years in his many
confrontations with voldemort the d.a
was originally comprised of almost 30
students so i won't bore you with the
name of each and every one of them
but you will most likely know that aside
from harry ron and hermione other group
members included cho chang neville
longbottom luna lovegood and ginny
weasley in fact it was ginny who
suggested that the group called
themselves dumbledore's army in an
effort to frighten the ministry into
recognizing the truth that voldemort had
returned despite briefly disbanding in
1996 dumbledore's army was present at
many battles and played a vital role in
the resistance against dark magic at
hogwarts while harry ron and hermione
were away searching for voldemort's
horcruxes in year seven members of the
d.a participated in the battle of the
department of mysteries the battle of
the astronomy tower and the battle of
hogwarts neville longbottom who led the
group in harry's absence was also
responsible for killing voldemort's pet
serpent nagini who also happened to be
one of his horcruxes
it would seem that the only real role
dumbledore played in the da was in
falsely admitting to cornelius fudge the
minister for magic at the time that he
had created the group he did so in order
to save harry and the others from
punishment
and with that we have come to the end of
another video
what are your thoughts on why witches
and wizards were so drawn to albus
dumbledore and his leadership do you
think this clearly demonstrates how
fortunate the wizarding world is that
albus decided against his plans with
gelat grindelwald way back when
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time it is our choices that
show what we truly are far more than our
abilities
[Music]
you